how did you pitch the company that
helped you finance all roads to perrla
i met the red sanders of red
entertainment red
productions through a
composer our composer named curtis heath
who did a lot of my um
short films and they were in for fort
worth and i was scouting in
down there and he was like hey have you
talked to red entertainment
i was like no i haven't and then um
they have offices in santa monica and i
was in la
at the time and sent over an email and
said hey we have a mutual friend
curtis um i'm i've got the script that
i'm
you know gonna be doing and um they
they read it loved it we had a meeting
and i loved people from texas
and then they were like sweethearts and
they were just great and
derek and red are just fantastic folks
and then um
i had i had my
uh mood reel i had my lookbook i had
pretty much you know um things this in
the
things set up and they they liked it and
then
i eventually became with gopot films and
reproductions and we
we held sort of certain um
you know uh meetings for investors and
things like that but
eventually we we cobbled up the
financing through
um separate investors and got that
all done uh red and
derrick were instrumental in and lifting
the project even further
in getting the script to uh lindsey
graham who who worked
at uh betty may casting and she was just
finished casting like um
a star is born and suicide squad and
things like that
and and and bigger features but she
she like really liked the script and
came on board
and that through that through
that our project um uh
picked up steam you know and we were
able to that's how we were able to get
um
actors to respond uh and things like
that
and and and uh that's how
we got lucky in terms of nailing some of
these really you know like dash
and addison and alex um and
the whole crew there um so
through with without that involvement
without red and
derrick and you know and lindsey i would
have been just shooting
um already perla with my father in there
acting you know so you know
somehow it just swims up um and then
mind you we also approached other tons
of other production companies who who we
wanted to partner up with
but you know you get hey we don't get
the script uh this
is not for us or we have a similar
project or you know it's
lots of things so that's why i even sit
back here
today just thinking it's a miracle that
it
it's even out there for people to see so
um so it goes back to that question when
is it good or
crap charles bukowski and i was like
man after just going through this
gauntlet uh i'll
reserve my opinions to myself
do you know why some of the investors
passed did they give you
when when these were people i know you
said that they had said it might be
similar to something i already have or
it's not for them
but when red sent it out to the people
in his network
yeah i again i it has to do with subject
matter
it has to do with connection has to do
with um
people connecting it you know like or
people wanting to change the story or
people want to do this or
or does it resonate so back to your
question go why do you want to write
this so you have to find people that
kind of
falls in that wheelhouse that believes
the same way
you do our film is
is about love and pain loss love lust
it's it's it's a dark and gritty film
and it's not
not for everyone it's it's um
to me there's messages of hope but to
others they might
see an ugly side of society that
doesn't hit you know especially
especially
so when an investor reads it are they
going to connect
connect with this you know um so
so they either do it they don't and you
go into the next person who who connects
with it
and and and and find that um so if
you're out there
it's just like first you have to
champion yourself
then find people that would help
champion you
and then and then keep going i think
that's
the steps when you're dealing with
production companies investors
what do they want to see first a log
line
synopsis of the script yeah so basically
basically on log line
gets everyone if you make a killer log
line i know it's
it's hard one two sentences uh your
pitch deck your lookbook
your mood reel uh to for them to get
them excited to read the script no one
wants to read anything
so you know um that's the problem
there's just a lot of scripts so how do
you get
um people to read it so you have to
entice them whether it's
through that log line through the
lookbook through the mood reel through
whoever's already attached or an actor a
producer
it just has and that's what they call it
a package i guess you package things so
it makes them it makes it harder for
them to say no
um so that's what i would do
as much as you can um so
start definitely start with a lookbook
so this
gives you an idea of
what the story is about the mood and
tone and then
you know you don't want to give a crime
thriller to
family drama production company unless
they want to branch off and do something
different because they're used to doing
that so just
you know maybe research comparable films
and what production companies that
have produced that in that particular
budget level and then approach them
you know things like that so um imdb
pros
will be your friend and um and just
research
and then and then just send out and
and hope someone reads it it took me
five years so
you know can you describe the all roads
to pearla lookbook how many images are
were in it
how many pages so basically it's like a
powerpoint
presentation i think mine had like 12
pages
and you know i'll say the how i have a
picture
the color palette the tone pictures from
from a lot of the pictures because i had
photographed already because of my
my photography so it's already a world
that i've already created
um then i would add you know the log
line the tone the theme
and then and then that's the feel
the visuals of it what this movie would
look like
uh i just and then i had a mood reel so
what that meant was i i clipped together
films
and music and made like a trailer of
how the film would look like it's
interesting because i just looked at my
mood reel
that i created i hadn't looked in in
ages and you should see it
through the trailer right now five years
apart to see
the the difference it's pretty
fascinating
um and
our composer not the sound designer was
like man
oh my god just saw that mood reel that
dance scene
looks almost identical to what we shot
didn't know what was what
you know it's kind of fascinating so if
you could
show what the what the world you're
creating
already without shooting it you don't
you know it's a quicker way than
creating a short film to to create that
atmosphere at least it will give you
entice you to read the script
that's all i wanted someone to do that
they knew i knew how to make visuals i
knew how to make sound
now you just judge me on my narrative
writing
um so that was my thought
process and how long is the mood reel
it's like two minutes you know two
minutes or two minutes and 30 seconds
something like that
or a previous they call it a previous
two um
so i do that now like if they send me
like if um
like uh a manager send you scripts to
read
and it's something you like and you want
to be up for it to direct
oh yeah that's a great script that's
fantastic i'll
quickly throw up a mood wheel and go
this is how i see the film this is what
i'll do
you know the tone and mood of it
so from understanding correctly it was
about three to four years of this
process
of you sending out the lookbook the mood
reel the packaging
for all wrote superla how many people
did you actually send it to
and what was their response time how
many actually read the screenplay
um i have an excel spreadsheet
of everyone who i would send it to i
don't remember
i don't i i know i kept it because i
like to keep track of it
a lot of people did not read or did not
respond
the majority majority of it
i was even determined to shoot it no
matter what
it was of that fateful sort of i only
took one
which was red productions so maybe
out of 50 to 100
red productions or i'm just i'm just
throwing another i know it was
pretty red productions came on and even
after red came on we went to
bigger production companies to kind of
um
get involved and that was
pretty much turned down turned down too
so we just
did it on our own so that process
i couldn't even get my friends to read
it i couldn't get fam like
it's that's what i'm saying no one likes
to read anything you know
even even what have you it's it's it's
it's that's why it's a miracle
that derek was like read it and loved it
so it just took
you know it was like oh what is the
story and what's that you know
um so to be long
one did um it took
we i submitted it for quite a few and it
was really just one or two that
responded
and then that was it you know that's all
it kind of took
knowing this knowing that it's very
difficult to get anybody to read a
script
is there anything you think you could do
to speed up this process the next time
around
uh i think the next time around um
it's it's it's getting easier but i
think most people don't make it to the
next
time around so the first time around
i don't think there is i think it's just
because
we're saturated and even
it's like you just it's like i always go
back to
that denzel washington quote you know
you stick around the
barbershop long enough you're going to
get a haircut so no matter it's the
third rejection
the 100th or the 400th you just got to
stick it out
and then you're going to get uh um
frustrated and you can just get tired
and go i don't need to wait for anyone
i don't need this production company say
yes i'm gonna
do it and then you set a date
uh once i set a date that's when i got
phone calls when i said november
13th a specific date i'm shooting no
matter what
this train is going then it started even
with actors and even with this stuff so
you have to be very specific can't go
i'm shooting in the fall
i'm shooting november 13th even at 2 p.m
we were rolling first night you know
things like that
that helped because that made it real
you know who
it was important to me it made it real
for me so i was like
then whoever i said that to i'm doing it
you know and then
so that's why i was like gosh i'm either
delusional
or naive or but i think you have to
so that's that's sort of what happened
so i
i don't know if i could do anything
different
and the other part that you said most
people don't
they don't get a second time to do this
i was just looking at the numbers of
something so someone sent the numbers
after your first feature was like you
know 17
you know for so that's not the majority
you know especially when you have
investors and people
so let's say as a producer to have a
sustainable career is to make
the investors money back it's not about
art you know
as a director you might be able to but
um
uh that's the fear and you look at the
stats and
what's happening so you have to mitigate
that risk
um you have to figure out ways to
maneuver that and that's
that's the business side that's that's
not going hey
this frame looks awesome oh that's a
great color color the
makeup and this it's how we can do this
again
and how can we deliver it and how could
we shoot it in time
and how to get it under budget um that's
just the reality of it
and um you know and
that's the brutal part of it
unless you shoot it with your iphone and
you know and
and and which is great and you have crew
but
there's only certain amount of favors
you could call you you know
you don't want to not pay people to to
work their
long hard hours and what they do they do
you know
it's there's there's only so much you
know um
i just feel that's just me personally
having you don't you know i don't want
to be a production company it doesn't
pay people to not do that
you know everyone needs to be paid so
there's it takes a lot of people
to make something and that adds up to
the budget um
so would you say it's easier for you to
get your emails returned
now that you have an excellent body of
work to point to
yeah i think so because you you have
that
first first feature um kind of done
so now they can't say oh he hasn't done
a first feature but now they could say
but he hasn't done a thriller you know
there's always something
but the whole name of the game i think
what's important
is if it gives you confidence it gave me
confidence to keep going so all these
little
wins so if you get any little win any
little thing keep it because there's
just so many losses
so you could get these this confidence
to keep going
now because of our perlis sleeping
plastic
script i got the management opportunity
there
and there and i had three other scripts
ready to rock and roll and a tv pilot so
i'm waiting on this
i wanted to make sure i'm not
when the opportunity to meet you talking
to people oh what are you doing after
this i'm not
fumbling and going oh i'm working on
something i was like
here here you go i've got tons left
and i wanted it to create a situation
where
um it was hard to people harder for
people to say no
you know like i don't want to wait
around because you're waiting around all
all these years so all that anxiety made
me write
you know and do all these kinds of
things so i wanted to make sure
i had things so um so i was able to
um get reps and then they they now help
push
pride the projects um and things and
and um you know thankful for that in
terms of
of of of trying to climb this
hill of what of creation you know of
of um getting projects made
um so i'm still learning each day this
whole thing you know so
which which
is fun
you